hello everyone my name is Jennifer Mars
Minh and this crazy contraption you see
me wearing on my head is a headset that
can read EEG or your brainwaves and I
took this headset and I put it on my
husband and I asked him a series of
questions and first I had him tell me
the truth and then I made him lie to me
and what that gave me is a labelled data
set of what his brainwaves look like
when he's telling the truth and what
they look like when he's lying and so if
you know anything about machine learning
you know you can take that data feed it
into a machine learning algorithm and
then build a classifier to perform a lie
detection so that's what we're going to
talk about today I do work for Microsoft
if you do have questions that don't get
answered today during the session feel
free to reach out to me on Twitter on my
blog and then Tim Huckabee and myself
are also going to be doing it ask me
anything
immediately following this session on
the fourth floor so I'm happy to take
questions there as well all right so
let's talk about this taking a step back
what is e e G and of course for the
official definition we can turn to the
source of all knowledge which is of
course Wikipedia right so you can you
can read the official definition there
essentially what what it is is the
electrochemical signals that are going
through your brain that can be measured
in a very non-invasive way for those of
you who are in the room early and saw me
messing around getting this thing on my
head
you saw that there's this the headset
has actually little felt pads and so I
took saline solution the same thing I
use on my contact lenses and put that on
the felt pads and then that helps it
read the signal so it can kind of read
those those signals that are going on in
your brain and I don't think I need to
say this to anyone in the room but just
just in case I can't actually do mine
reading with this all right you put this
on someone's head you don't know what
they're thinking or anything like that
but what I can do is I can create
mappings between patterns of EEG and
actions either in the physical world so
for instance like making a drone fly
with the power
of your thoughts by thinking up-up-up or
in the digital world and I'm gonna show
you I'm gonna attempt to show you that
in a minute by trying to move a cube
with the power of my mind and then
secondly I can see patterns in this data
or more accurately I can train a machine
to see patterns in this data and to
learn based on historical data what
those what those patterns actually mean
so using in supervised machine learning
you can use historical data from the
past to make future predictions so we're
gonna see how to do that as well in the
field of lie detection alright so let me
just start with a quick demo so this
headset is actually made this isn't a
Microsoft thing I do work for Microsoft
but this is not a Microsoft thing this
is actually made by a company called
Emotiv which has offices in San
Francisco as well as Taiwan it's a
female founded company woman and so yeah
yeah so it's a great but it's a really
neat headset um that I that I have been
just busting after forever I'm the
founder of the company Tenley did a demo
with it as a TED talk way back in 2010
and ever since then I wanted headsets so
badly so I want to show you a little
kind of snippet of what some of the
people are doing with today and some of
the things that got me super excited
about it so I'm gonna start by showing
this is a piece of software that
actually is made by a motive that came
with a motives with their actual
software so this isn't software I wrote
this is software that comes with the
headset and it shows you a couple things
so you can kind of see that everything
is reading green right now which is good
that means it's got strong signal from
all of the 14 nodes resting against my
scalp so that's great if I switch over
to here you can see everybody look this
way is it looking that way one way the
other way yeah okay cool when I'm
looking I can't actually see what's
happening in front of me so hopefully
that's working blinking blink blink
blink some blinks and then raise your
eyebrows smiling coils so I didn't
actually train it for this one but you
can see it's picking up some of those
things now wire this is important and
where this is going to come into play
later is that facial movements all
so feed into EEG de that's what you
should be taking away from this so just
moving your face is enough for it to
pick up with EEG so some of this is
actually affecting the data so just bear
that in mind and then this is the demo
that really got me excited with about
this headset when it was first shown and
as a TED talk um all those years ago and
so what I'm going to attempt to do right
now is move that cube with the power of
my mind okay so everybody's brain has a
unique signature much like fingerprints
where we all have you know slightly
different fingerprints your brain has a
unique signature as well and so you know
you everyone I'll show you actually in
just a second I can show you like the
wave patterns and such so like my waves
might spike it like 24 and my husband's
might spike it like 3 so you need to
take into account things like that so
what I'm gonna do is start by just
training what my brain looks like at a
neutral state all right so this is just
gonna be me I'm gonna train it for
neutral so what's gonna happen is it's
gonna take eight seconds and I'm just
gonna try to close my eyes and go to my
happy place in front of a crowd of you
know 650 people staring at me I'm gonna
try to relax and just like try to think
ABB's kind of nothing at all just kind
of go to a neutral relaxed state ok so
we're gonna do that for eight seconds
there's gonna be an awkward little
silence and we're all gonna be okay with
it
alright and then when I am gonna close
my eyes so when it says done well
somebody just yell out loud zone you
open your eyes okay we good with that
okay thank you
all right so we're gonna train now eight
seconds happy place here we go
training now
thank you you guys were awesome with
that okay so I'm gonna go ahead and
accept that training I think I was
sufficiently relaxed and now what I'm
gonna do is there's a series of actions
that they've already programmed it to do
right and so I'm gonna do you pull I'm
gonna Majan pulling the cube towards
myself okay and so what I'm gonna do now
is I'm gonna think pull with my mind
okay so this is just pattern matching
right we're just doing really basic this
isn't even machine learning here I'm
just thinking pull and what it's gonna
do is take the pattern that my brain
waves are using and I don't necessarily
even have to think Pole I could be
thinking hamster dance but whatever I
think as long as I'm thinking that thing
consistently whenever I want it to pull
it should work right so I make sense
all right cool so now we're gonna map
that pool and my brain activity to to
that motion so now I'm gonna train it
again by thinking pull for eight seconds
it'll be another eight seconds here all
right so now we're gonna go ahead and
pull Oh what was that that's not good
there we go oh okay yikes all right so
it lost signal right in the middle of
training so that's not good but let's
see if we can get this up alright so
let's try one more time hopefully that
didn't affect anything too bad and here
we go
one two three
okay I'm gonna say no I'm actually gonna
train at one more time because I was not
totally focused there because the thingy
the blip threw me for a second so they
do it one more time a little more
focused all right one more two three
here we gonna go train here we go
okay so now when I hit yes the cube is
gonna be live so now what we're gonna do
is see if I can kind of repeat that
pattern of motion I'm gonna try to think
pull the same way I was thinking before
and see if we can actually make this
cube move okay all right let's do it all
right now pull oh come on yeah you have
not lived until you've moved to keep
with your mind I'm just I'm not gonna
lie
I feel like Jean Grey every time I do
that it is so cool all right that's the
whole reason I bought the headset really
was was to do that okay so you can see
how I got pretty excited about the
potential applications here so let me
just show you a quick two-minute snippet
of what people are doing with this
device today and some of these these
possible potential applications so this
is a really like just a short part of
Tammy's TED talk from back in 2010 and
then if you would like to you can go
back and watch the whole thing it's only
like 1012 minutes long it's pretty short
so go watch the whole thing later but
let me just show you what people are
doing today and I have to hit the play
button there we go
[Music]
that you can control the world with your
mind and also colors lighting sound and
effects can dynamically respond to your
emotional state to heighten the
experience that you're having in real
time the moving on to some applications
developed by developers and researchers
around the world with robots and simple
machines for example in this case flying
a toy helicopter simply by thinking lift
with your mind the technology can also
be applied to real-world applications in
this example a smart home you know from
the user interface of the control system
I love this dude because notice how he
always uses his hands and does the like
these are not the droids you're looking
for saying like watch him he's off he's
got to do his hand he said not the
droids you're looking for
he's my favorite he's awesome yeah now
this is actually my favorite application
of the technology though right here
finally to real life-changing
applications such as being able to
control an electric wheelchair in this
example facial expressions are matched
to the movement
all right we'll cut it off there we'll
cut it up there but so you can see
there's a lot of really cool things that
people are doing with this already
there's a lot of academics and
researchers and and a lot of people
exploring and it could be anything from
game development so imagine like having
a real time feedback loop where you
could tie into people's emotions right
so let's say you can actually sense one
of the things I didn't show you is um
there's kind of a sense of like
excitement level that's mapped so
imagine that you're playing a game and
the you can actually sense that the user
is getting a little bored so like make
another zombie jump out right so you
could actually base it real-time on the
actual users feelings and expressions
and how they're interacting with the
game and be able to add additional stuff
based on that and then of course the
thing that really gets me there's kind
of the smart home applications and other
applications as well but my favorite is
the one at the end when you consider
someone like the the case of a
paraplegic or someone paralyzed from the
neck down being able to use facial
expressions and the power of their
thoughts to move an automated wheelchair
like those kind of things are are really
exciting to me when we have the power to
you know use technology to make the
world a better place like that
so all these life-changing examples all
these cool things that we can do to
benefit humanity and what does Jennifer
choose to do with it
lie detection on our husband yeah way to
help humanity Jen so um let me tell you
where I kind of got this idea you guys
probably watch all the same you know
criminal drama shows that I do so you
probably heard the the fact that some
people question how effective polygraphs
are and so the typical polygraph where
you're you're measuring things like um
galvanic skin response like have sweaty
your palms get and you're you're
blinking raid and your heart rate and
things like that and the critics of this
method say that those things actually
measure your emotional response so if
you're really nervous sometimes you get
this the same effects as if you were
really you know guilty versus lying or
telling the truth versus lying and so I
started thinking so I again let me let
me say really clearly I do not claim to
be a neuroscientist I have very little
there's actually very little known about
the brain it's
it's amazing how much we still don't
know about the brain but I did get my
master's degree in artificial
intelligence and machine learning and
one I did take a look one brain science
class while I was there
and one of the things I remember is that
when you're telling the truth that tends
to activate the recall centers in your
brain and when you're lying that tends
to activate the creative centers in your
brain so I started thinking if I have
this headset that's reading from these
fourteen different points on my head
could I do that like would that maybe be
possible so it was one of those things
where I just started this as a fun side
project let's see if this would actually
work and tried it out and so in good
little former graduate student you know
thing I listed out my goals and my tools
and blah blah blah okay so here's the
fun part
my actual experiment procedure so I my
first my first victim here was my
husband was my actual husband and I sat
him down in a chair and I did make him
close his eyes and the reason for that
was actually two reasons number one I
was actually sitting next to him because
I had the the headset has to say pretty
close to here so that it picks up over
it uses proprietary technology kind of
like bluetooth to talk back and forth
and so I didn't want him out of range so
he was sitting pretty close to me and I
didn't want him reading the questions
over my shoulder because I was actually
putting a mark in the data when I
started asking the question and like
when he finished answering so that way
with all this brain data I could slice
out just the part where he was thinking
about the answer right and so if he was
reading it over my shoulder that I
wouldn't be getting an accurate slice of
when he was actually processing the
information so that make sense all right
so that was one reason and the second
reason was because you guys saw earlier
how when you actually let me run the
other thing as well I'll run test bench
and show you this for a second too when
you do have a whole bunch of I'll come
back to this verse again when you do
have facial movement that gets picked up
in the data because remember how we were
able to pick up like the blanks and the
smiling and the raising eyebrows and
stuff in that data so EEG these things
are actually affected by facial
movements too right so I didn't want him
to be like scratching his face or
blinking or anything like that so I just
said just to get the day
as clean as possible like in the test
runs I said can you just you know close
your eyes and just you know ant listen
and answer like that so that was the
second reason and then I ran this tool
called the mode of test bench and I'm
launching that right now for you and we
can see that in a second but I asked him
a series of questions and those are some
of the questions right there at the
beginning and I asked him truth and then
lie and differentiated the data and I
did do a nice confusion matrix where
some of the correct answers to these are
yes and some of the correct answers to
these are no because I wanted there to
be a nice confusion matrix of like
true/false yes/no I wanted things on
every single quadrant right and so like
do you we don't have a dog then no we
don't have a dog yes he does have a PhD
no he doesn't have red hair
yes he's married no he does not have
five children well at least he does not
have five children with me he may have
five children but if so then we have
another problem so all of those things I
asked and let me show it to you real
quick tour so you can see like the
actual process so I was using this tool
this is test bench which also came with
a motive and you can see oh no I went
orange on one of them that's okay so
what this actually does is it's here's
all fourteen of the different signals
right here and so you can see if I kind
of go calm for a second pretty
flatlining there and then yeah that
makes it crazy so you can see that so
you can see kind of different brain
activity and how it actually shows up
like in the in the thing so it's pretty
cool so that's what this does so this is
the actual EEG reads and you can turn
off certain things so the different
sensors if you want to focus just on
certain sensors like I can turn off some
of these readings and just look at some
of them and focus in on certain ones too
that I find to be more useful and then
when I was actually collecting this data
I used this little marker tool where I
was sending manual markers so if I open
where did I put those documents emotive
so here's one of them actually let me do
the data two one
I think that one might be a little
better so I have a couple markers here
and so for example this question asked
things so I could if I when I was asking
Eric the questions I could say you know
ask the question or I think I said
question asked said the question got his
answer and then sent a question answered
and you can actually see see the little
one and the two and the data here so
that allows me to extract out I just
went through and wrote a little python
script
afterwards to be able to extract out
just those signals and then move them
over so make sense
good you guys see that that's pretty
straightforward okay cool the sampling
rate is a hundred and twenty eight
readings per second if you do the math
on that that works out to approximately
every eight milliseconds it's taking a
reading so so pretty good there all
right so that's all I can think of to
say about that so let's go back here
then for a second and then oh and here's
here's the documentation of the actual
process that first run I wanted to
document it like for my blog and stuff
later and you can tell my husband is
really happy about helping me with this
research no Jennifer don't have an
Ashley Madison account can I please go
watch TV no no honey I'll decide when
we're done hahaha okay and then here's
the sensor quality so for those of you
who again were in the room a little
early you might have seen when I was
putting it on my head before it went all
green and beautiful like that there was
actually a lot of yellow and red and
black and Jennifer shifting around
chunks of hair so that I can have yet
more pictures of me on Twitter with
crazy hair so it's actually really funny
if you look at when a motive actually
presents this stuff every single time
without fail they use a bald guy because
they're so easy like my husband is also
follicly challenged and like when I put
the headset on him it's just like you
put it on and bam it works and it's
fabulous with me it's like a 20 minute
long process of okay getting it on and
then shifting chunks of hair around to
make sure it's getting a good reading
everywhere and it's a complete pain but
anyway so you can see though once it's
reading there's a basically an
enumeration of different levels of
signal
so you can get you know it's really good
to use for data cleaning later to make
sure you're getting the highest quality
data signals and so Green is represented
by four so that means that's the
strongest signal quality and then
there's progressive levels of signal
degradation so yellow and accent orange
and red and then black means it's not
reading any signal at all all right and
then all of that is collected in the
data - actually I didn't show you the
data you guys want to see the data let
me jump over to the data so when I
record that in test bench like I was
showing you here as that data is being
recorded then they actually store it in
a proprietary format but then they give
you a nice little convert to CSV thing
with it and so you run the convert to
CSV and then once it's a CSV it looks a
little something like this can you guys
read that okay I do I'm gonna make a
little bigger okay so here is what the
data actually looks like so first of all
there's a counter the counter actually
just counts up to 128 and resets and
because that's the 128 readings per
second so that kind of gives you the
sampling right there and I did not use
that data at all I just do that out I
threw this out as well here are the
actual relevant values so these are the
14 different places and I'll show you
how those map to areas on the scalp and
just a second but we have something a f3
f7 f3 kind of all these fun names o 1
and O 2 etc etc and so those are our 14
different things right here and then we
actually have there's a gyroscope in
there as well so measuring kind of the
angle of your head and I did not
actually use this in my first runs but
that's kind of on my to-do list that it
might be fun to play with someday
because then you think about if any of
you guys watch like the World Series of
Poker and you know how sometimes like
more inexperienced poker players have
little tells well maybe their tilt their
head a certain way when they're lying or
something like that so there might
actually be something to that data so
that's like on my list to play with
someday but I haven't done anything with
it so far but that's the the gyroscope
stuff here is the marker column so the
marker column remember when I was
sending markers I sent the one when the
question was started and then a to when
I finished he finished answering so I
could extract out that stuff this will
read all zeros except for when I sent
the one in the
and then I can just parse this file and
then pull out everything between a1 and
a2 and use that as a single question
answer session here's the sink this
doesn't matter um here's the timestamp
the way they do timestamp is a little
bit a little bit crazy because they they
have it as two separate things so here's
the seconds value and then here's the
milliseconds value in two different
columns so I actually do something at
the end to make those a single time
value as opposed to two just to make the
math easier but here's the value in
seconds the value in milliseconds and
then this is the this CQ represents
contact quality so that's those levels
from from four to zero from green to
black that I was showing you before so
you can see kind of when you first get
started and it first goes on your head
it might read zero for a second and then
this one was reading green after that so
that's good and so what I do but I was
collecting data is I would throw out all
this zero stuff at the beginning to get
a good accurate a good good accurate
data all right so here's contact quality
and I have that for each one of the
fourteen different sensors so our
contact quality for each one of these
and you can see where they map to the
places on the brain based on the diagram
I'm going to show you in a second and
then here's where their data ends right
here and then after that I added three
columns myself um the first column is my
label right because in machine learning
we need we need a nice labeled data set
if you're gonna do supervised machine
learning so for this particular session
I was at this person was telling the
truth so I put is truth is one so now I
have that this is truth data marked in
there and so then when I make
predictions when I want to predict if
something is truth or not it will give
me zero if it's lying and one if it's
the truth and then here's the time value
and this is just using those two values
that you had before taking you know the
seconds times a thousand plus the
milliseconds to get the time all in one
value like so so I did that right here
and then after I did the initial
experiment on my husband and such I
wanted to see if I could do it
general-purpose so I started collecting
data from lots of different people and
just for privacy reasons I wanted to not
associate their names with it so I put
this is user 18 in my data
right here and so here's user 18s data
all right so that's just a quick look at
the data that I was getting so now if we
jump back here you can see we already
saw this the signal quality and that was
represented in the Excel spreadsheet by
that C Q underscore each one of those
names and then here's the actual mapping
of where those different things you saw
those columns in the Excel spreadsheet
here's where they actually mapped to the
positions on the brain and this is a
heads up thing so you're looking from
the top downward where that little bump
on the top is the nose and those are the
ears t7 and t8 all right here so you're
kind of seeing this view right here eek
right like that
a f3 and a f4 right here here's the T 78
the the ones that like hurt your ears in
the back or o 1 and O 2 right here so
all of those are the are the various
sensors that we have here and where they
match the places on the brain okay so
now one of the things that I did do was
usually when you have an idea that you
think is super cool someone has already
thought of it right so I did go out on
the internet and did some research and
thought hey has anyone thought about
doing lie detection in conjunction with
EEG before and what has been their
results and such and I was doing some
research on this and I did read about
something called the p300 ERP and so
some you know government agencies and
researchers are looking at this this and
what this actually does is the piece 300
ERP response actually measures that
flash of recognition so let's say you're
walking through n DC n DC Sydney here
and you're walking through the crowd and
you see someone and you get that oh I
know that face from somewhere you know
that feeling you get that's the P 300
ERP response so it's that oh I know that
from somewhere maybe you don't rember
the context of you know they could have
done a kindergarten with me maybe I
worked with them maybe I saw them at a
user group before whatever but that
little flash of recognition is called
the P 300 ERP and if you look at it and
on a if you look at it plotted this is
what it actually looks like it's this
little dip there's this kind of big
relative dip that you see right here and
it's active the reason they call it P
300 is because it's activated roughly
after the visual stimulus that you got
and so you can see right here the dip
300 or 500 is probably more accurate but
it's uh it's a bigger it's a little dip
that you see right right afterwards and
so government agencies have actually
used this response in EEG in conjunction
with lie detection so the idea is
instead of like a polygraph or you're
asking people yes or no questions and
measuring those responses you have a
headset like this so probably a better
quality one or maybe a hospital-grade
one I don't know but you use some kind
of EEG detector and you can then say
things like I shouldn't say that this is
no this is actually a really really good
headset in terms of like the value there
was actually a study done I was reading
studies about the various EEG readers
and this one is one of the highest in
terms of like the amount you pay versus
how high-quality the the signal is it's
very very good so I am actually a huge
fan of this the Sun set so what they
actually found is so if we're trying to
use this in conjunction with detecting
guilt right and and lie detection what
they did is they sat a person down and
had a headset on their head and then
asked show them images right so they put
pictures in front of it some of them
were like just neutral images whatever
but then say you put a picture of the
crime scene or the murder weapon or
something like that and if you put
things like that in front of them and
they get that flash of recognition then
that can show that okay maybe they know
more than they think they do or may have
seen this before or there's some kind of
you know some kind of recognition
happening and so they actually some
people are experimenting with using this
to help with lie detection and the
little chart that you see right here is
actually probably the silliest way of
saying this but essentially what that
means is it's the information that of
what the suspect recognizes
correlates to something that someone
with no intimate knowledge of the crime
should know then you know maybe they're
guilty right and if they if they know
something that they shouldn't know then
maybe they're guilty and if they know
they
know something that someone who didn't
know anything about the crime doesn't
know then then it's probably okay so
very very straightforward thing right
here if the this is the information the
suspect is expected to know information
that should not be known to the suspect
and that information that the crime that
only a perpetrator would know and so if
they know stuff that is correlated to
information that only the perpetrator
would know then maybe they're guilty
right like kind of like da right it's a
lot of pretty charts to say it something
pretty simple but kind of cool all right
so what I took away from this kind of
this was really really interesting stuff
it's a little different than the way I
was approaching it but what I one thing
that I took away from this that was
really really useful is I was actually
wondering I had no idea in what
timeframe these responses were happening
like in terms of number of milliseconds
after the stimulus and so knowing that
something like that recognition flash
actually happened you know 200 to 500
milliseconds after the tip stimuli I was
like okay my sampling rate of 128
readings per second which is roughly
every eight milliseconds it's probably
good then if I'm getting that every
eight minutes so that was a big takeaway
from me that okay because I was that's
one of my concerns was is the sampling
rate high enough you know am I getting
information fast enough to be able to
know if this is working well and from
this I was like okay I think I'm
probably good with every eight
milliseconds time okay so now let's
transition for a second
to our machine learning so I used a drum
machine learning to implement this I
work at Microsoft and so I like to play
with all of our new technologies for
machine learning and there's a lot of
cool stuff we have machine learning
there's some new stuff that's gonna be
come out in the Ignite timeframe which
I'm really excited about there's the C
NT K which is our deep learning open
source framework so we have all kinds of
cool to us cognitive services which are
some pre-built models that you just call
with the REST API so we have all kinds
of cool stuff and so for this I just
wanted I was just playing around and
wanted to kind of rapidly iterate and
stuff so I chose Azure machine learning
and Azure ml is pretty cool there's 25
pre-built algorithms that are already
included in there that you can call and
utilize and there's a whole bunch of
modules for importing the data and
cleaning the data and then you can train
models and test models and then the
deployment story
is beautiful it's literally like a
button press and it takes your model
stands it up as a rest endpoint
generates a token so that only people
with that security code can can call the
web service and it's just it's so easy
like the deployment is just awesome so
that's one of the things I love the most
about it because usually deployment is
the worst so uh that's that's really
cool so that's kind of some of the power
of Azure machine learning so I use that
and here is one template that you can
use if you were looking at Azure machine
learning and trying to figure out you
know it's a web-based tool so you don't
need to download a lot of stuff so you
go there and you kind of have to drag
and drop or I'm sorry you drag and drop
little modules and string them together
to create a data flow and so in this
case you could take a data set like this
and then do some kind of data cleaning
and I use various modules for that and
then machine learning we split our data
and the reason for that is if I have
this nice labeled data set of you know
here's all this you know great EEG data
and then here's whether he's telling the
truth or lying if I fed it all of that
data and then I went back and I wanted
to see if it worked and I you know took
some of that data and said okay for this
EEG pattern is he telling the truth or
lying it's re gonna know the answer
right or something pretty close to the
answer cuz I trained on that data right
so it's not gonna do as you know that I
can't really trust the answers of that
it's performing that well so typically
in machine learning what we do is when
we have a nice label data set like that
you hold back a certain amount of the
data so you can assuming the law there's
lots of different ways to do this
there's cross-validation and some other
techniques as well but one technique you
can use assuming you have a sufficiently
large data set is to use just a simple
3070 split so I take 70% of my data
train it with that data and then hold
back 30% and then once I built that
train model I apply you send in like
just the features or just the EEG data
of the of the 30% you've held back see
what the model generates and that I can
compare that to those known right
answers that I've held back does that
make sense okay so that's why that's why
we do that in machine learning so I took
70% of the data
trained a model with that and then this
puts a trained model essentially and
then I take that 30% of the data I held
back for my test data I apply it and
what that does is the score uses only
the features puts it into the model gets
back the results and then compares it to
the the known right answers that we have
in the test data and then that gives it
a score of accuracy numbers precision
recall things like that and then you can
evaluate that side-by-side with another
model so I do that exact same thing over
here but maybe over here I use a
different algorithm and then I compare
the two and see how well they do or once
I've settled on an algorithm I start
tweaking the initial parameters because
that can affect accuracy and things like
that so this is kind of the the art part
of data science where you iterate and
iterate based on your data and see how
you can get the the best results there
all right so is that all kind of makes
sense all right the one big thing that's
probably still missing here is okay Jen
if you just said that there's these 25
different algorithms if I don't have a
machine learning backgrounds how do I
know which algorithm to feed into the
model so enter the Asherah machine
learning cheat cheat cheat cheat cheat
cheat cheat cheat all right so this is
an amazing thing with a large friendly
do not panic button right in the middle
and so what this does is actually give
you a lot of different ways to use talk
about data so you can do things like so
regression and classification so those
are both forms of supervised machine
learning and with supervised machine
learning we're again taking that
historical data from the past a label
data set of historical data and then
using that to make future predictions
and the difference between our
regression and classification is that
regression predicts a number right so
like the cost of a home how much your
energy bill is gonna be things like that
you would use regression for and then
classification is when you're predicting
between distinct categories so who's
gonna win the World Cup this team or
Brazil who is going to it are my sales
numbers gonna be over or under it
doesn't have to be binary either it
could be you know what what color does
this series of pixels most closely map
to you know red orange yellow green blue
etc alright so that's classification is
when you're dealing you're trying to
predict between discrete buckets
discrete categories and
and regression is when you're predicting
a number right and then anomaly
detection is really interesting anomaly
detection is when you're trying to do
this with a highly unbalanced data set
okay so imagine the problem of credit
card fraud detection all right when you
have your whole database of all these
you know all this credit card data you
may have a whole bunch of you know valid
transactions and then out of your whole
data set probably the number of
fraudulent transactions is going to be a
really small subset and then the number
of known fraudulent transactions it's
probably gonna be even smaller still
right so you have a very small number of
known fraudulent transactions and then
you have all of these valid transactions
and so when it's very unbalanced data
set like that it's hard to build a
conventional classifier using some of
the other methodologies and so anomaly
detection is something that can
specifically account for that so
basically you can train it with with
what normal looks like and then when you
get something that's kind of outside the
bounds of normal you can utilize that so
credit card fraud detection uses anomaly
detection I've used it for oil and gas
pipelines to detect you know problems
with pipeline flow Network intrusion
detection it's really good we use it on
our networks at Microsoft
fun fact people try to hack the Xbox
Live Network like all the freaking time
like everybody wants more gamer points
right so like that network is like
constantly being things so we have like
network intrusion detection algorithms
running on on that all the time
so all kinds of cool stuff with anomaly
detection and then clustering clustering
is actually um unsupervised machine
learning so we've been talking about
supervised machine learning using a
labelled data set to make future
predictions that's supervised
unsupervised machine learning you don't
need a label with your data set you can
just have a whole bunch of data and then
clustering algorithms just group like
things together so that's really good
for things like building a
recommendation engine um you might want
a group like movies together or like
restaurants together so that people who
like one might like others and that sort
of thing okay all right so quick test if
I have a bunch of EEG data and I'm
trying to predict if my husband is
telling the truth or lying should I use
classification clustering anomaly
detection or regression
classification 10 points to Gryffindor
yes that it's a classification problem
so we would go here predict categories
am i predicting three or more or two
categories two right I was just
predicting between truth or lie I did
not ask any questions like does this
dress make me look fat where the answer
may be somewhere in the middle okay so
that is exactly right so then you can go
and use these um these algorithms are
the best ones to kind of get started
with and then if you look at the cheat
sheet it actually gives you a whole
bunch of really great information about
where each algorithm shines for example
SVM's that stands for support vector
machines those are really good when you
have lots and lots of features like over
a hundred features I'm feeding into your
algorithm the things that predict your
label are your features so if you have a
whole bunch of things that might affect
it SVM's work really well there's linear
models right here as well as I'm
nonlinear things like decision tree and
SAAM bowls here and you can see like the
boosted decision trees are really really
accurate but they also take up a large
memory footprint so it kind of tells you
some of these kind of pros and cons of
each of them so you can kind of look at
those and decide okay which one might
work best and try a couple of those I
usually start with one linear and one
decision tree to start and see how it's
performing better and then iterate from
there based on that because if a linear
model works great because they're super
fast but they don't always work because
real life is messy alright so if you
would like to download that cheat sheet
and print it out and hang it in your
office like all the cool kids do you are
totally welcome to you can download it
at AKMs
Azure machine learning cheat sheet and
then I also have a blog post that I did
on getting started with a dream machine
learning if you'd like to play around it
with it more yourself and that's a AKMs
swag hack ml that's got a whole bunch of
interesting things so one of the things
I put is um if you want to just get
better at machine learning and practice
it you need two things like number one
you need cool datasets to play with and
then you need cool problems to solve and
so I give you here's a whole bunch of
places that have really cool datasets so
like I have sources of where you can
find cool data to play with I have a
tutorial like an end and walkthrough is
linked from there a link to where you
can provide feedback which is actually
if you guys don't know about that you
know the Microsoft like user voice thing
where you can go and submit
back that is really good to snoop on if
you guys don't do that right now like if
you want to see what's coming because
they actually mark some of them as this
is in development or this is we're still
talking about it this is in
consideration in development whatever so
you can kind of see what features are
coming sometimes if you snoop around in
there so just you didn't hear from me so
really really cool stuff but there's a
whole bunch of great resources linked
from there I did write it for a student
audience so the the actual title of the
blog post is how to win a hackathon with
Azure machine learning yeah but just
ignore the spin in the first paragraph
and the rest of it is just like getting
started without your machine learning
alright and then if you'd like to see an
end end demo for like how do I get data
into Azure ml how do I do data cleaning
with it because that part is really
really important how you get the data in
a format that a machine learning
algorithm can use it effectively and
then how to train a model test a model
deploy a model you know call the model
all that stuff I have a whole end-to-end
demo predicting whether or not someone
would survive the Titanic based on
demographic information about them like
their age their gender how much they
paid for their ticket stuff like that so
you can go and check that out there's a
video of that online there okay so now I
ran this on my husband I collected the
data I've explained the experiment
procedure I put it into Azure machine
learning so let's go look at it here is
my model that I built and I am going to
right click on the evaluate at the very
end and hit visualize and there is a
chart here I'll show you how to read it
so this is this is a chart that plots
the true positive rate versus the false
positive rate so false positives are
when you say something is true and it is
not in fact true and true positives are
true all right so false positives are
bad and true positives are good so
perfection would be if we had false
positive rate of 0 so to plop it on the
chart 0 would be like that all the way
up and then true positive rate we would
want that to be 1 which is 100% and go
go all the way up here to Shoop all
right so the sense
the tighter it hugs this curve the
better your machine learning algorithm
is is performing okay so you want it to
be as clue you know hug this as tight as
possible and then this is usually really
hard to see our projectors but there is
like a thin gray line that goes up the
middle right here so this is essentially
5050 random chance a monkey flipping a
coin all right so you want your
algorithm to be performing better than
that if your algorithm is not performing
better than that start over there was a
problem there go back go back to the
drawing board all right
so all right you can see this one is
doing kind of man this was the linear
algorithm but this one this was the
decision jungle is actually doing pretty
well so if we go down and look at the
the data here you can see the true
positives and the true negatives are
high which is good we want those to be
high and then the false negatives and
false positives are low which is good
and then we have an accuracy of around
93% and high precision and recall and
and stuff as well so I started to think
oh my gosh there might be something to
this maybe there may be you know the
this this is preliminary stuff but it
looked kind of like there may be
something to this and so literally you
guys literally like God like I think it
was like a week or two right after I had
done this initial work with my husband
my team had an off site alright so I
work on a distributed team my husband my
my manager sits in Minneapolis I sit in
Detroit
we're like spread out all over the US
and so you know once or twice a year the
whole dysfunctional family gets together
and we have an off site and we talk
about our stuff and all that kind of
things and so um and this was the year
when we had to do we had a commitment we
had a one of our my Jobs was to do a
whole bunch of channel 9 videos you guys
know channel 9 Microsoft's YouTube
channel 9 dot I miss Dan comm good stuff
ok go watch him all right so that year
we had a goal where we had to deliver
like we had to create like X number of
channel nine videos that got you know Y
number of views each so they had to be
not only Channel nine videos but popular
Channel nine videos like those kind of
things so that was one of our views so
our marketing department had actually
hired a camera crew and brought them to
our off-site just in case you guys feel
like making some videos right now just
go ahead you know so so
but that gave me an idea right this had
kind of worked on my husband so I
grabbed my manager and I was like hey
remember the headset that you let me buy
I've been doing some initial machine
learning work with it and would you mind
if I just put it on you and asked you a
few questions and he was like yeah sure
whatever
and he didn't really know what I was
doing yet so I got my manager and then I
grabbed the camera crew and I was like
let's have some fun all right so first I
had to build a class cart and I wanted
to build it specifically for my managers
brain waves okay because I haven't done
the work to generalize across all people
yet so first I asked him a bunch of
questions and made him tell me the truth
are you a male yes
have you ever worked for Microsoft yes
okay so you guys get the idea right and
then I made him lie to me do you want HD
yes no he does not you currently have a
pet yes
nope do you have your eyes yes
okay so you guys get it right now what
would you do if you had access to your
managers brainwave ah
do you believe Microsoft is the best
company in the world to work for yes
am I going to get a promotion this year
okay so you guys all heard that totally
awkward little giggle right so what did
it mean did it mean he had some good
news and he couldn't share it or did it
mean I totally thought like I had to
know so I did what any girl would do and
I ran back to my hotel room that night
and build the classifier with his
brainwaves so what I did was I did the
same process that I had done with my
husband
I took the truth data uploaded it to
Azure machine learning to collide Atta
trained a model that was specific to my
manager deployed it so it stood up as a
rest endpoint and then I wrote a really
ugly Windows 10 app because as anyone
who has ever seen a Jennifer Marvin demo
knows I am not that good at UI design
I'm really good at algorithms
yeah but design has never been my strong
point so I made this really really ugly
Windows 10 app and what all it does
basically is it calls the the web
service button and so I I trained with
just the truth and lie data and then I
was gonna ask it this is this program
will basically ask it the the two
questions that I asked at the end that
data all right and we'll call those and
then I also tried to do something cool
and I made a little thing that gave you
the confidence levels as well so it'll
show like how true or how how much of a
lie we think it is all right so here we
go do you believe Microsoft is the best
company in the world to work for my
manager said yes my algorithm says he
has an iPhone
and he's really into design I'm just
saying we might have like a closet like
Mac fanboy on our hands all right and
then the real important question am I
getting commercial this year my manager
said yes and my algorithm said yeah and
I am delighted to announce that I did
get the promotion so you can see there's
a lot of things you can do
this is just a I've had so much fun
working on this project and I have like
all these other ideas for how you can
use machine learning in conjunction with
the eg like I uh I can't even there's so
many here's a couple things that I'm
looking at doing um next oh okay
so after kind of the initial data run
sighted with my manager and my husband
and such I did kind of some second data
runs I don't expect you to read all this
so let me just call out a few major
points so the first the first couple of
runs I did I took I just did one marker
per question and then I took like a time
interval around it and so then after
that on the second run I started doing
um like a marker before I asked the
question I asked the question all of
that and then a marker after they answer
so I get all the data more accurately I
started taking neutral brain state
recordings so one of the things I need
to do still is like normalize it across
all people so that I could just plop it
on anyone's head where I don't have
training data for them and see if I can
do it so I'm to be able to do that I
started you know even saw how when I was
doing the thing at the beginning where I
was pulling the the the cube towards me
I needed a neutral brain state to be
able to normalize my brain waves versus
kind of like the collective holes so I
started taking neutral brain state
recordings for people as well so that
way I could use that for data
normalization i'ma started asking more
questions because you know the more data
the better and it's a pain to get it
down someone's head so once it's on I
want a lot of good data per person oh
this is kind of interesting
so I started switching order to reduce
fatigue effect so the idea behind that
is fatigue effect is it's a very
beginning like if I take your data at
the beginning it's kind of fun right
because this crazy lady puts
head set on your head and then she's
asking you all these questions and
you're like oh this is kind of fun and
you can see your brainwaves or whatever
it's kind of cool but it gets boring
really fast okay and so what was
happening is if I ask all the questions
where I asked people to tell the truth
first and then lie like that excitement
emotion might kind of get all correlated
with the truth data and then kind of the
boredom at the end associated with the
lie so what I did was I for some people
I asked him to tell the truth first and
then lie and then for other people I
asked them to lie first and then tell
the truth so that way that you know kind
of the the emotional response we'll get
will get distributed throughout the data
so that make sense okay so that's a
fatigue effect all right and then I
started asking additional data about the
test subject as well so how many of you
guys seen that show brain games do they
have it in Australia I'm not sure okay
yes I'm seeing some nods okay well
there's a show called brain games and
they they do all kinds of tests with the
brain like they had some driving
challenges where they took like older
more experienced drivers who had more
driving experience and then had them
like do an obstacle course where they're
like throw stuff in front of you while
you're driving and you have to swerve
and stuff and then they had younger
drivers who were you know less
experienced driving but you know their
brains were maybe a little bit sharper
because they were younger and they
compared the two of them against each
other to see who would do a better job
and that sort of thing and so I started
collecting and actually the younger
people won which was kind of interesting
the older drivers were able to avoid the
obstacles better so for the small sample
size they did have it wasn't a huge huge
study but anyway so I started collecting
a couple extra things like age for one
just in case there is you know
degradation in the brain over time
I collected age I collected gender I
collected whether you're right or left
handed because have you guys heard the
the thing that maybe you're you're that
correlates to the dominant side of your
brain I don't actually know if that's
true or not but more data is good and I
don't have to use it so I started
collecting that as well so all kinds of
extra data to that I can use and then
finally I'm mixing truth and lie in a
single session so I asked them to tell
the truth and then lie like back to back
to kind of try to tease out some of
those confounding variables to make sure
it's not stuff that's specific to a
session that
gets in there rather than the actual
truth or lie all right so here's some of
the questions I added there's a couple
of them in there they're all were meant
to be yes or no questions although
there's some other stuff in there too
then we won't get into it right now but
there's other stuff that some situations
when you wouldn't not necessarily use
those and then extra date I already
talked about this use your IDs the
gender whether they're right or
left-handed here's the fun part
okay so here's different ways I started
doing feature extraction on this data
because I have all this interesting data
so this is time series data right so
it's it's these waves like that and so
there's different ways you can do this
so one thing is unrolling the waveform
and what that means is essentially I
have over time so for each one of these
fourteen sensors I have you know data
over over some time interval which is a
specific of how long that
question-answer lasted and so you can
basically take like all fourteen of them
and like unroll them in the same order
and then use that as kind of your whole
feature vector so that's one way to do
it
another way is something called wavelets
so what that is is dividing a time
signal into frequency bands and there
was actually a really good EEG thing on
Kaggle if any of you guys are familiar
with Kaggle it's a data science
competition site and they did a
competition about being able to
differentiate if someone was trying to
grasp with their hand versus lift and so
you can think of the application for a
pair of pulley or for someone who had
their their arm removed or an amputee if
you were able to give them a prosthetic
and then in their brainwaves map what it
looks like when they're trying to graft
versus lift you could actually kind of
build some of that into the prosthetic
potentially and so there's um there's
just some interesting applications there
and then the person who actually won
this actually did it using some of the
low-frequency time domain stuff so there
may be something to that to you so I was
playing with that there's a wonderful PI
EEG library by Forrest Chang Bao I have
never met him but I am eternally
grateful because he opened sourced it
and so I used that and pulled in some of
the feature extraction that he was using
another thing is state machines okay
so this is actually kind of interesting
because when you think about all the
stuff that is actually happening in the
brain when when I ask these questions
like from from the user perspective
first they have to listen so they
actually have to decode those signals
and figure out what it is that I'm
asking so they have to do the auditory
work to figure that out then they have
to kind of process the question and see
what I'm asking then they have to decide
whether they're gonna tell the truth or
lie then they have to come up with an
answer and then they have to do the work
to you know the auditory work to
actually say it out loud right to
vocalize the response okay
so there's kind of like a mini little
state machine happening in there and if
I can zoom in on that and then zoom down
even further into just like the truth
lie part of that that will help be more
effective so I was hidden Markov models
kind of work well with state machine
type things so that's another thing I
was kind of playing with comparing to
the neutral brain state I already kind
of talked about that so to be able to
normalize across all people you want to
do that comparison of kind of everyone's
brain waves against the average to be
able to make better predictions ERP so I
talked a little bit about that I'm sorry
I never defined it when we're talking
about the P 300 ERP but that stands for
event related potential and so it's
actually a different way of processing
EEG where you're taking some essentially
averages over time so it kind of helps
weed out some of the noises or some of
the noise so using ERP instead of the
raw EEG is another thing that I've kind
of played with and then in Samba 'ls are
a technique in machine learning where
essentially you use multiple classifiers
together and then some of the some of
them can kind of help account for the
error of previous ones so you can in
Samba lab unch of things together and if
you look at who is winning these Kaggle
challenges almost everyone is using an
infallible to do that so it's basically
kind of matching up a lot of things
together
I'm sorry using a lot of classifiers in
conjunction to come up with the best
results and then finally um deep
learning I think of honestly the key to
solving this right because if you think
about what I'm really trying to do it's
really really similar to the problem of
speech recognition right you guys have
all seen audio files you know that when
you
talk.you makes these audio waveforms
which are very similar to the brave with
the brain waveforms that I just showed
you right and everybody has slightly
different voices different timbres and
pitches and all those other things I
don't really understand because I never
really paid attention a music class but
you know what I'm saying that those
things are all in each of us speaks a
little bit differently but it can still
recognize hopefully the words that we're
saying when we're saying the same words
and that's what that's what speech
speech has done and so really it's a
very similar thing where it's again time
series waveform data that I'm processing
and I'm sure and everybody has a brain
signal that's a little bit different
much like our voices are all different
so it's really really really kind of
similar problems and speech recognition
has been solved with deep learning like
it's a solved problem at this point and
so I think deep learning could actually
solve this too and the only reason I
haven't done it yet is because I don't
have enough data with deep learning you
actually need to use lots and lots of
data to do it effectively and I've been
kind of collecting headset data from
people in my spare time hahaha with my
high-stress job at Microsoft and my
three children and all that so it hasn't
caught as quickly as I would like but
when I do deep learning is a great thing
and there are great tools like the C NT
K as well as things from other companies
that can process those okay so that's
some of the techniques so the next steps
I'm collecting data from lots of people
now to be able to do a general-purpose
one as well I'm experimenting with
different features to improve the
accuracy like you saw on the previous
slide those are some of the things I'm
experimenting with and then implementing
a real-time feedback loop there's
something the only thing the thing
that's holding me back there otherwise
this would have been done a long time
ago the other thing that's holding me
back there is that I need that thing to
convert this from from the the
proprietary format into CSV
automatically and they actually have
that embedded inside of their tool and
it's not like a command-line thing that
I can call and so I've been going back
and forth with a mode of support trying
to get them to just give it to me as a
console app and then once I have that
that should be like not hard to code so
and then what I could do there some
really awesome demos where I can stick
it on someone live and ask questions so
I wanted I want to do it to Satya
Microsoft's CEO and a dream big right
reach for the stars all right and I do
want to say thank you to all the people
so when I had an early version of this
and I demoed it to the Azure machine
learning team and they all started
drooling and we're like can we help you
this is so cool
so I do want to say thank you to all the
people who have helped me and made
suggestions on the experiment procedure
and Python scripts and all kinds of
other stuff the whole team started
helping me with this and the ending
result is so much better now
based on everyone who was able to
contribute some stuff all right so in
summary this headset is awesome and so
cool I've sold all these other ideas and
I do feel like Jean Grey every time I
move something with my mind which is fun
as a machine learning is an amazing tool
and made it really really fast and easy
to get up and running with this
technology and to iterate quickly and
try different things and I I really
really love it and husbands and managers
beware mind control is next thank you
guys so much
[Applause]